.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Aus dem Autoradio:
"Uf u Dervo" von Gölä *
# ... uf der Suechi
für nes neus Dehei.
# Si gö hüt no uf u dervo.
# Eifach uf u dervo.
Hei, ei, ei,
in dieses Wintermärchenland
sind Sylvia und Markus Buob
zusammen ausgewandert,
um ihren Traum des Hauses am See
zu verwirklichen.
Und das Ganze
auch noch hochschwanger.
Auf diese turbulente Zeit
schauen wir heute mit ihnen zurück.
Und zum Abschluss
des Jubiläumsjahres
gibt es auch noch ein Wiedersehen
mit unvergesslichen Momenten
aus zehn Jahren "Auf und davon".
Die Buobs heute
als vierköpfige Familie.
Juna und Paula heissen die beiden
Töchter von Sylvia und Markus.
2017 hatten diese ihr Leben komplett
auf den Kopf gestellt. - Tschüss.
Sie verabschiedeten sich aus der
Schweiz, wanderten nach Schweden aus,
schufen sich in Snokebo ihr kleines
Paradies und gründeten eine Familie.
Jetzt ist gerade
meine Fruchtblase geplatzt.
Ja, jetzt haben wir es geschafft.
- Jetzt geht es erst los.
Ausserdem
bei "Auf und davon - Souvenirs":
Abschiedsschmerz und Neuanfang -
wie Auswanderer die ersten Schritte
im Paradies erleben.
Wasserrohrbrüche
und andere Missgeschicke -
wie die Helden die
alltäglichen Katastrophen meistern.
Hallo!
- Frohe Kunde und Hiobsbotschaften -
wie Auswanderer
auch grösseren Krisen trotzen.
Das Elend
ist hier halt schon sehr gross.
Und: Männer und ihre Maschinen -
worauf sich Männer
beim Auswandern wirklich freuen.
# U sie stigen i Flüger,
flüge mit de Vögu furt,
# chöme nümme hei.
# U si lö hie aues zrugg,
uf der Suechi für nes neus Dehei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u drvo.
# Uf u dervo!
Mona Vetsch und die Souvenirs
aus zehn Jahren "Auf und davon".
* Vogelschreie *
Du kannst schauen, wer klopft.
Hallo! Wer hat geklopft?
Wir haben geklopft.
Hey, Markus! Ich freue mich.
- Mona.
Hallo. Herzlich willkommen.
- Hoi, hoi, Juna. Und wer bist du?
Das ist Paula. - Paula!
Dich kennen wir noch nicht, gell?
Die vierte im Bunde.
- Hoi, Mona. Schön, bist du hier.
Sylvia, schön euch zu sehen.
- Willkommen, hallo.
Wir kommen einfach mal schauen,
wie es euch geht.
Auf den ersten Blick hat man
das Gefühl ... - Uns geht es gut.
Sehr gut, sogar,
würde ich behaupten.
Viele behaupten,
wir haben es "geschafft"
nach zweieinhalb Jahren,
aber wir kommen immer noch an.
Wirklich?
- Ich behaupte es.
Ich habe immer noch das Gefühl,
erst gerade gekommen zu sein.
Wirklich?
- Ja.
(In der wohlig-warmen Wohnung
der Buobs
fühle ich mich auf Anhieb
willkommen.)
Hast du geholfen, Kuchen zu backen?
- Mhm.
Mmh!
Schau, Juna, du kannst das haben.
Wie war eure Zeit, seit wir
euch hier zurückgelassen haben?
Eine sehr intensive Zeit.
Ähm ...
Als die Fernsehausstrahlung lief,
kam für uns
eine andere intensive Zeit,
weil wir sehr viele Besucher
aus der Schweiz bekamen.
Das habt ihr gemerkt?
- Ja, extrem. - Sehr.
Dann hattet ihr
noch mal ein kleines Baby.
Ja.
- Wie ging das?
Wir müssen es ganz ehrlich sagen:
Als Paula zur Welt kam,
wussten wir wirklich noch nicht,
wie wir die Saison bewältigen. - Ja.
Wir sagten:
Es darf einfach nichts passieren
und die beiden müssen mitspielen.
Sonst geht es nicht.
Was heisst das?
- Sie hat einfach schon mal ...
Ihr Termin lag eigentlich
auf dem letzten Sendetag.
Wir dachten:
Wenn die an dem Tag kommt ...
Und sie kam extra eine Woche später.
- Gut, sie hat mitgespielt.
Auch sie machte super mit,
als wir ausgewandert sind.
Sie kam wirklich auf den Termin.
Sie beide machen einen super Job.
Es ist schon etwas wahnsinnig.
Schon hochschwanger auswandern
ist das eine,
und wenn das Geschäft so richtig
anläuft, kommt das nächste.
Ja, es ist ...
- Ja, Wahnsinn.
Ja, die letzten drei Jahre
waren sehr vollgepackt.
* Juna plappert. *
Wenn du drin bist,
ist es etwas anderes.
Es ist irgendwie ...
Du bist irgendwie drin,
du bist in einem Lauf.
Dann nimmst du es nicht so wahr.
Jetzt, wo es ruhiger wird,
schaust du zurück
und gehst durch:
"Was haben wir alles gemacht?"
Da denkst du: "Sind wir bekloppt?"
Ab und zu stehe ich da und denke:
Nein.
(Fast drei Jahre ist es jetzt her,
dass das Abenteuer der Buobs
angefangen hat.)
* Sanfte, glockige Klaviermusik *
So, dann starten wir.
Hier, wenn man den Schallkopf
so hält, sieht man die Wirbelsäule.
Hier haben wir eine wunderschöne
Darstellung des Profils.
Nase, Nasenbein, Kinn.
So.
Dann schauen wir mal das Herz an.
Es ist ganz, ganz gut.
Für mich ist immer das Schönste,
wenn man das Herz schlagen sieht.
Dass es lebt, dass es sich bewegt.
Es ist natürlich schon ...
... ein unglaubliches Gefühl,
dass es in einem drin wachsen darf.
Deshalb ist es für uns beide
immer das schönste Erlebnis.
Mir ist, blöd gesagt,
alles mehr oder weniger egal.
Ich habe nur darauf gewartet,
bis ich den Herzschlag gesehen habe.
Alles andere ist Zugabe.
* Sanfte Klaviermelodie *
Hier haben Sylvia und Markus
bis vor drei Jahren gearbeitet:
im Renovationsfachbetrieb
von Sylvias Eltern.
Diese wollten die Firma
an die Auswanderer übergeben.
Ich kenne mehrere, die das Geschäft
des Vaters übernommen haben.
Die haben es übernommen,
weil man das halt machen sollte.
Und ich weiss:
Sie sind nicht glücklich.
Es gibt ganz viele, die lieber
etwas anderes machen würden,
als den elterlichen Betrieb
zu übernehmen. Aber es ist halt ...
Es stimmt für uns,
das ist das Wichtige.
Denn wir müssen unser Leben leben.
Fast vier Jahre lang
versuchten Markus und Sylvia,
den Erwartungen der Familie
gerecht zu werden.
Ein megaschöner Kronleuchter.
Aber ich glaube für Schweden, ja ...
Sylvia
leitete im Betrieb die Finanzen,
den Showroom
und organisierte die Ausstellungen.
Hallo.
- Hoi.
Hoi. Ich war noch draussen.
- Ciao.
Markus war Geschäftsführer.
Warst du mit dem Hund unterwegs?
- Ja.
Beide gaben Vollgas in ihren Jobs.
Ich merkte einfach,
dass es v.a. Markus nicht gut ging.
Und irgendwann zwingt einen
das Leben auch ein wenig,
hinzuschauen.
Irgendwann
mussten wir uns einfach eingestehen,
dass es einfach nicht das ist,
was wir wollen.
Diese Kronleuchter
möchte ich eigentlich verkaufen.
Bei den Schwiegereltern von Markus
wird das Abschiedsfest
für die Auswanderer vorbereitet.
Schwiegervater Theo
hilft mit dem Regenschutz.
Sie haben 40 Leute eingeladen:
Freunde, Bekannte
und Sylvias Geschwister.
Lang ersehnt, dieses Fest.
Das bedeutet: Der Countdown
ist eingeläutet und wir gehen bald.
Was muss ich machen?
Hier kann man Spiesse machen aus ...
* Lachen *
Theo hat Mühe damit, seine Tochter
nicht mehr in der Nähe zu haben.
Der Plan war, dass Markus und Sylvia
irgendwann das Geschäft führen.
Bis zu dieser Sitzung,
an der sie erläutert haben,
dass sie andere Zukunftspläne haben.
Sie wollen auswandern.
Das Auswandern
hat mich nicht gross überrascht,
denn sie waren immer Weltenbummler.
Von daher ...
Und äh ...
Ich habe nicht gespürt, dass es
in diese Richtung gehen könnte.
Es war im Moment schon deftig.
Musst du hier
die Zigarren auspacken,
wenn ich daneben den Kuchen mache?
- Ja ...
Kein Problem.
Hier sind noch die Utensilien.
Hier!
Theo konnte die Firma mittlerweile
verkaufen - an einen Mitarbeiter.
Aber hinzunehmen,
dass Sylvia und Markus
sie nicht weiterführen wollten, fiel
ihm und seiner Frau Beatrice schwer.
Es war ein Prozess, bis wir das
irgendwie akzeptieren konnten.
Denn sie hätten
sehr gut in die Firma gepasst,
haben es auch supergut gemacht.
Wir waren ehrlich gesagt
schon ein wenig enttäuscht.
Aber eben.
Wir haben den Vorrang eigentlich
immer ihrem Glück gegeben.
Fonduekuchen.
- Ja.
Ja, Quiche.
Tschüss.
- Ciao.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Ciao. Sag allen liebe Grüsse.
- Mache ich, ja.
Macht's gut, tragt Sorge.
- Ja, ihr auch.
Bau Mami etwas auf. Tschüss.
- Ciao.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Markus schaut zu ihr.
Ist sie schon durch?
- Ja, sie ist runter.
Auf und davon.
Bei "Auf und davon" zeigen wir immer
zwei Seiten der Geschichte:
Wir zeigen immer die, die gehen,
wie ihr,
aber es bleiben auch immer
Menschen zurück, wie eure Eltern.
Von ihnen hört man nachher
relativ wenig.
Wie war es für eure Eltern?
Ein wenig haben wir gehört: Sie
haben sich eigentlich schwergetan.
Im Prozess der Auswanderung
habe ich extrem viel gelernt
von meinen Eltern.
Sie haben uns gehen lassen und
einfach kompromisslos unterstützt.
Obwohl sie eigentlich andere Pläne
für euch gehabt hätten. - Ja.
Ich glaube, sie hatten immer auch
die Hoffnung, dass wir zurückkommen.
Aber je öfter sie kommen,
desto mehr merken sie:
Die kommen nicht mehr.
- Nein, danke.
Ihr hättet euch ins gemachte Nest
setzen können, hattet eine Firma,
man rollte euch den roten Teppich
zur Übernahme aus,
alles wäre da gewesen.
- Ja.
Das wäre der einfache Weg gewesen.
Wir hätten ein gutes Leben gehabt
in der Schweiz. Das ist so. - Aber?
Es hätte uns
nicht glücklich gemacht.
Man macht manchmal Fehler im Leben,
die man sich eingestehen muss.
Wir haben gemerkt, dass in der Firma
zu viel Verantwortung an uns hängt,
mit der ganzen personellen
und finanziellen Verantwortung.
Und das stimmte nicht.
Und wir hatten in der Schweiz
nicht die Möglichkeit,
ein Grundstück am Wasser
zu erwerben,
in diesem Umfang,
wie wir es jetzt haben.
Und äh ...
- Das ist ein grosser Punkt.
Das ist Lebensqualität.
Und es ist natürlich auch Freiheit,
die wir gefunden haben.
Wir erzählen immer
die Geschichten von Menschen,
die ihren Traum verwirklichen.
Das ist etwas Schönes.
Andererseits kann man auch sagen:
Es hat auch etwas Egoistisches.
Habt ihr euch das überlegt?
Natürlich überlegst du dir das,
wenn du gehst.
Und dann?
- Aber es ist irgendwie ...
Wenn wir geblieben wären
und nicht egoistisch gewesen wären,
wären wir jetzt
vielleicht nicht glücklich,
hätten vielleicht keine Kinder,
wären vielleicht
nicht mehr zusammen.
Uns hätte es in dieser Situation
nicht gepasst.
Jetzt kann man ganz viele Szenarien
erfinden: Was wäre, wenn?
Von daher war es eigentlich so,
dass der Egoismus
der Weg zu unserem Glück war.
Manchmal muss man es sein.
Es ist ja mein Leben.
Das ist etwas,
das wir bei ganz vielen Auswanderern
immer wieder sehen:
Im Moment,
in dem man sich entscheidet,
muss man sich einiges anhören.
Sogar unser bärtiger Hermann,
der nach Kanada ging - sogar er -
musste sich zuerst mal
etwas die Leviten lesen lassen.
Kurz bevor sich die Schönbächlers
auf nach Kanada machen,
ist Hermanns Mutter Elisabeth
zu Besuch.
Ja, ja, das ist gut.
Lisa nimmst du sowieso mit, gell?
Ich weiss ja schon lange,
dass sie davon geredet haben.
Ich habe einfach immer gehofft,
es käme nicht dazu.
Irgendwie hätte ich schon gewollt,
dass sie hierbleiben.
Denn wir haben auch ein Haus,
also ich,
und ich habe immer geglaubt,
das sei irgendwann für den Sohn.
... auf den Boden gemacht?
Und nicht für fremde Leute.
Umgekehrt hat sie drei Kinder,
nicht nur mich.
Und ich bin der, der
seit 30 Jahren sagt, er wolle gehen.
Und, ja ...
Darauf hätte man sich
eigentlich einstellen können.
Vater hat immer
mit  d i r  gerechnet.
Du warst der, der ...
... für den er alles aufgebaut hat.
Er hat immer nur an dich ...
Ja, nun kann ich mich
doch noch einen Moment setzen.
Tschüss, Mütterlein.
- Ade, Büblein.
Manchmal muss man auch
Abschied nehmen von Menschen,
die noch gar nicht bereit sind,
verlassen zu werden.
Ja, es muss etwas laufen.
- Ja.
Also für mich wäre das nichts,
zu diesen Kameltreibern.
Sicher?
Dort reitet gerade eins vorbei.
Eine Altbekannte.
- Hallo.
Hoi, Brigitte.
Schön, dass du kommst. Hoi.
Auch Jean-Maries erste Frau,
Brigitte, die Mutter seiner Kinder,
ist da.
Und natürlich auch die Kinder
samt Anhang und Enkeln.
Samuel, Jean-Maries ältester Sohn,
tut sich schwer
mit den Plänen des Vaters.
Ja, es ist schon nicht nur
mit positiven Gefühlen verbunden.
Ich hätte mir
für meine Kinder schon gewünscht,
dass sie mehr
von ihrem Grosspapi haben.
Sämi.
- Tschüss, Vater, mach's gut!
Kommt schon gut.
Wir kommen bald runter, ist gut?
Okay.
Tschüss.
* Ein Kind quengelt. *
Kommt!
Ciao, bis bald. Mach's gut!
- Tschüss.
Macht's gut.
- Mhm.
Amon, du musst hierbleiben.
- Du musst zu Mami, Amon, gell.
Tja!
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Warte, ich nehme gleich so eine mit.
Auch Teres Brunett hat
einen schweren Abschied vor sich,
bevor sie nach Venezuela auswandert.
* Glockenschläge *
Es ist gar nicht wüst, Teres.
Naja, es hat schon ...
Sie besucht das Grab
ihres Sohnes Daniel,
eines von zwei Kindern
aus erster Ehe.
Ich würde sagen.
Vor acht Jahren,
im Alter von 23 Jahren,
hat sich Daniel das Leben genommen.
Mind. einmal pro Woche
besucht sie seitdem sein Grab.
Am Anfang war es schon
eine sehr schwierige Zeit.
Und jetzt ...
Ja.
Es war schon
ein riesiger Eingriff ins Leben.
Es geht mir sonst
eigentlich schon gut.
Es geht immer besser und
ich versuche, vorwärts zu schauen.
Es gab auch schon Leute,
die mich gefragt haben:
"Kannst du das Grab zurücklassen?"
Ich sagte: "Er ist mir ja immer nah,
in meinem Herzen."
Und somit nehme ich ihn auch mit.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Ciao.
Tschüss.
- Tschüss.
Tschüss, mach's gut.
- Tschüss. Du auch.
Tschüss. Mach's gut, flieg gut.
- Tschüss, du auch.
Gell, Schatz.
Wir bleiben in Kontakt, gell!
Du wirst mir fehlen.
Bye-bye.
(Abendstimmungen
wie diese in Snokebo ...
Ready, Lady?
... unbeschwerte Zeit
mit den Kindern verbringen
und das Gefühl,
richtig entschieden zu haben -
all das hilft,
dass der Abschiedsschmerz
mit der Zeit kleiner wird.)
Juhu!
Ist mir unterwegs eingefallen, dass
der letztes Jahr zugefroren war.
Wow, ist das schön!
- Ja. - Ja!
(Aber speziell die ersten Tage
an einem neuen Ort
sind für viele Auswanderer
nicht gerade paradiesisch.)
Das neue Leben von Marcel Buholzer
und seiner Frau Trix
beginnt im Dunkeln.
Sie sind in Griechenland angekommen.
Im Dorf Elounda
beziehen sie eine Wohnung.
Sie haben diese Unterkunft
während ihres letzten Aufenthalts
in Kreta gemietet.
* Handy *
Hier ist noch kalt.
Trix wusste genau, wie sie ihr Nest
in Griechenland einrichten möchte.
Einige dieser Möbel hat sie
extra noch in der Schweiz gekauft.
Irgendwie haben wir uns total
verkalkuliert mit den Möbeln, gell?
Du sagtest, wenn du die Zimmer
siehst, weisst du genau wie.
Ja, aber Ella gab die Masse durch
und das Zimmer war viel grösser.
Scheinbar nicht.
Gut.
Ich habe hier ...
- Du hast die Betten ausgewählt.
Hier habe ich mir
einen langen Gang vorgestellt.
Jetzt frage ich mich,
was wir mit unseren Kommoden und
dem ganzen Zeug machen. - Ja, eben.
Deshalb sagte ich:
Was willst du Kommoden kaufen,
wenn du doch nicht ...
Wenn du hier bist,
siehst du die Grösse offiziell.
Jetzt haben wir zu viel Material.
- Genau.
Hier kann man theoretisch noch
etwas hinstellen, dann ist fertig.
Ja. - Hier ist der Balkon,
hier sind die Wandschränke.
Deshalb sagte ich:
Was ist mit dieser Kommode?
In jeder Ecke hat es Wandschränke.
Sie hatte alles anders im Kopf
und es musste einfach sein.
Es konnte nicht warten, bis man hier
ist und die offizielle Grösse sieht.
Das hatte sie auch
viel grösser in Erinnerung.
Jetzt haben wir noch Platz für
zwei Nachttische, fertig, Schluss.
* Betrübte griechische Klänge *
Erstmals, seit sie das Anwesen
im letzten Herbst gekauft haben,
reisen Claude und Anja mit Hund Gino
in ihr neues Heim nach Italien.
Wo ist jetzt das Ding?
Ah, es hat Strom.
Glück gehabt.
Also, Gino! Guck mal,
ob irgendwelche Fremden hier hausen.
Er macht schon wieder so ein Chaos.
Der Vorbesitzer, ein Engländer,
hat das Haus unaufgeräumt verlassen -
sehr zur Freude von Gino,
dem Trüffelhund.
Das erste Fundstück von Gino:
eine Riesenwurst.
Die hat er bestimmt hier ...
Das riecht hier wahrscheinlich
seit Monaten.
Was ist das denn?
Ist das Abfall?
Komm! Matratze aufpumpen.
* Knurren *
Oh!
Mein Baby. Los!
Ruhe, Schluss!
* "Uf u dervo" von Gölä *
Nicole ist endlich in Santa Teresa.
Das Dorf kennen die Kinder bereits.
Sie haben hier
ihre Sommerferien verbracht.
* Spannungsgeladene Perkussion *
Die beiden Häuser haben Nicole
und Mike im Internet gefunden
und für drei Monate gemietet.
Jetzt, da Nicole die Unterkunft
zum ersten Mal in Realität sieht,
macht sich Ernüchterung breit.
Oben sind wahrscheinlich die Zimmer.
- Die Treppe ist kaputt.
Es ist Horror.
Gibt es hier Licht?
Nein, das ist momentan
nicht angeschlossen.
Was Nicole vorher auch nicht wusste:
Die Bungalows
liegen ausserhalb des Dorfes,
mitten im Dschungel.
Es gibt nur ein kleines Problem:
Ich kann den Schlüssel nicht finden.
Aber morgen bringe ich ihn.
Was ist mit dem Licht?
- Ah, das Licht.
Mache ich später.
Okay, bye-bye.
Pura vida in Costa Rica!
Vamos! Costa Rica!
Pura vida! Venga!
Pura vida, das volle Leben.
Flotte Sprüche
können nicht darüber hinwegtäuschen,
dass die beiden Häuser
nicht eben paradiesisch sind.
You?
Come here, come here, pura vida!
Pura vida, okay. Hasta luego,
gracias. - Hasta luego.
Buenas noches.
Sie machen es eben schon
mit ihrer Art. - Ja, ja.
Gell? Einfach nichts vorbereitet.
Weinst du? Oh, Schatz!
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Nein, nein.
In der Schweiz
hätte ich es viel schöner gefunden.
Ich will nämlich nicht hier sein,
hier oben.
Weisst du was?
Habt ihr Hunger? - Ja.
Wir löschen hier das Licht,
damit nicht alle Viecher reinkommen.
Es ist wirklich extrem abgelegen.
Im Moment kann ich
überhaupt nicht ehrlich sein.
Es geht gar nicht,
weil ich die Kinder bei mir habe.
Obwohl ich viel mehr zu sagen hätte.
Ich bin hier. Es ist alles gut.
- Nein.
Ich bin hier.
* Wimmern *
Wir packen noch den Rest aus.
Er kommt helfen.
Momentan sind die beiden nur Gäste
in ihrem eigenen Guesthouse,
denn der Mietvertrag
ist noch nicht unterschrieben.
20'000 $ Übernahmegebühr
haben sie mit Max ausgehandelt.
Ein stattlicher Betrag
für Monika und Peter,
die für ihren Traum
vom eigenen Guesthouse
ihre Pensionskasse aufgelöst haben.
Welches Zimmer
hast du für uns reserviert?
Das grosse.
- Dort hinten?
Ja, ja.
Dann brauchen wir mal
irgendwas Flüssiges.
Ja.
Ah, super.
Hier habt ihr Platz fürs Gepäck.
Ich denke, ihr habt viel.
Ja, schon ziemlich.
- Ja.
Ist gut.
- Super. Es riecht gut hier drin.
Innerhalb von nur vier Tagen haben
Monika und Peter damals entschieden,
das Guesthouse zu übernehmen.
Länger kennen sie auch Max nicht,
der immer noch
der aktuelle Chef im Haus ist
und der irgendwie
nervös zu sein scheint.
Ähm, in den einen Zimmern ...
- Jetzt machen wir mal aus, bitte!
Ja.
(Dunkel
ist es zwar auch in Schweden,
aber nicht etwa, weil wir
die Kamera ausschalten müssten.)
(Im Winter sind die Nächte hier
rabenschwarz und lang.)
(Am frühen Morgen macht sich Markus
Buob bereit, um arbeiten zu gehen.)
Also, ich gehe.
- Paula, hoi.
Ja.
- Päuli, ciao.
Jetzt hast du beide aufgenommen,
beide ohne Schoppen.
Hey.
- Ciao.
(Flüsternd) Hoi, Paula.
* Markus lacht. *
Ciao, bis später.
- Bis nachher.
(Nach den Renovationsarbeiten
hier auf dem Hof Snokebo
hat Markus Buob eine Zeit lang
für den Astrid-Lindgren-Park
gearbeitet.)
(In der Zwischenzeit ist er als
Schreiner selbstständig unterwegs.)
(Die Schreinerarbeiten
machen mehr als die Hälfte
des Einkommens der Buobs aus.)
Wir haben vor Kurzem
mit anderen Auswanderern diskutiert:
Wann ist man angekommen?
Wann hat man es geschafft?
Angekommen sind wir,
aber wir lernen immer noch.
Es wird wohl auch noch
eine Weile so bleiben,
dass man lernt,
wie Schweden funktioniert.
Speziell bei mir,
wenn ich auf Baustellen gehe.
Beim Umgang mit anderen Handwerkern
etc. lernt man immer.
Das ist halt ...
Sie ticken anders.
Es dauert halt, bis man
wirklich drin hat, wie sie ticken.
* Friedliche Gitarrenmusik *
(In der warmen Jahreszeit
haben Buobs viel zu tun
mit den vermieteten Zimmern.)
(Jetzt aber ruht
der Gastbetrieb der Auswanderer.)
(Flüsternd) So. Perfekt.
Aber, nein!
- Doch, ein wenig müssen wir schon.
Ein wenig.
Rosmarie auch noch ein wenig.
Hand vor den Mund.
Du musst die Hand vor den Mund
halten, wenn der Husten kommt,
nicht, wenn er schon vorbei ist.
* Husten * Ja, so.
Oh, Paulchen!
* Lachen *
Das ist nicht so gut.
Das ist nicht so gut für dich.
* Lachen *
Im Winter
bin ich in erster Linie Mami.
Das geniesse ich jetzt extrem.
* Husten *
Im Sommer
kommen viele andere Dinge dazu,
wenn wir die Häuser vermieten
und der Garten viel Arbeit gibt,
also der ganze Hof.
Jetzt im Winter ist es toll,
dass ich mir so viel Zeit
nehmen kann für die Kinder.
(Viel hat sich verändert,
seit Sylvia hochschwanger
hierhergezogen ist.)
(Auch wenn es einem vorkommt,
als hätte sie sich erst gerade
auf die Geburt von Juna
vorbereitet.)
In Schweden steht die erste
Schwangerschaftsuntersuchung an.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Wenn die kein Englisch können,
haben wir ein Problem.
Ich musste kurz schauen,
was "gebären" und so heisst.
Der Geburtstermin rückt näher.
In der Frauenklinik in Vimmerby
will Sylvia einen Termin
mit der Hebamme vereinbaren.
* Telefonband auf schwedisch *
Ah, Moment.
Sylvia und Markus haben
einen Schwedisch-Grundkurs besucht
und ein paar Privatlektionen
genommen.
* Piepen *
Es geht nicht.
Sie sagt, man solle
die vollständige Nummer eingeben.
Aber ich habe nur diese Nummer hier
im Internet.
Die Telefonzeit stimmt auch.
* Telefonband auf schwedisch *
Oh.
* Freizeichen *
Sylvia hat beschlossen, direkt
bei der Hebamme vorbeizufahren.
Ehemann Markus
kommt selbstverständlich mit.
Fahr jetzt hier rein.
* Glockige Klänge *
Das ist MFV.
...C.
- MVC. Das heisst?
MVC. Mödravardscentral?
Könnte das sein? Ich gehe fragen.
- Fragen wir einfach mal.
Was willst du anderes tun?
* Piepen *
Jag är Sylvia.
- Du är Sylvia?
Jag heter Britt-Sophie.
Du är jätte välkommen.
Tack sa mycket. - Markus.
- Du är Markus? Välkomna.
Ni ska för bebis?
- Ja.
Pratar du Svenska
eller mest Engelska?
Bara liten. Engelska är bättre.
- Engelska, okay.
Die Auswanderer haben Glück:
Die Hebamme spricht Englisch
und nimmt sich spontan Zeit
für eine erste Sprechstunde.
You can put your shoes on this one.
- Okay, thank you.
Bisher verlief die Schwangerschaft
ohne Probleme.
Dennoch sind die Buobs vorsichtig -
Sylvia hatte bereits
drei Fehlgeburten.
* Hohles Rauschen
des Ultraschallgeräts *
Man hört die Herztöne.
Aber - da ist noch etwas anderes.
You know,
it has ... the hiccups.
- Ah!
* Markus lacht. *
Hic!
Now?
- Now, yeah.
Nicht, dass sie denkt,
er trinkt zu viel. Hallo?
Nein, nein.
Danke.
Also alles in Ordnung.
Tack, Britt-Sophie.
Bis zur Geburt wird die Hebamme
Sylvia regelmässig untersuchen.
Was heisst "nächstes Mal"?
Till Mandag.
Ja. Vi ses.
* Glockige Musik *
(Juna ist jetzt zwei Jahre alt
und besucht die First Skola.)
(Heute ist aber schulfrei.)
Schau jetzt!
Jetzt kommt wieder eine Böe.
* Juna spricht unverständlich. *
* Kaffeemaschine *
Wenn wir nicht vorgehabt hätten,
eine Familie zu gründen,
hätte es auch gut
ein anderes Land sein können.
Aber weil es ein Wunsch von uns war,
eine Familie zu haben,
haben wir natürlich darauf geachtet,
in ein Land
mit gutem Bildungssystem zu gehen.
(Juna kann als Tochter
von Einwanderern davon profitieren,
dass sie drei Tage pro Woche
zur Integration in eine Schule darf,
obwohl Sylvia
noch Mutterzeit bezieht.)
Wir haben uns entschieden, sie
schon sehr jung dorthin zu geben,
damit sie die Sprache lernt.
Denn jetzt ist sie
in der sensiblen Phase
der Sprachentwicklung.
Und es läuft ihr sehr leicht.
Und es ist natürlich wichtig,
dass sie Freunde hat.
Wir wollen sie ja nicht
isoliert aufwachsen lassen.
* Paula plappert. *
Hier.
* Sägegeräusch *
(Markus hat sich in der Region
innert kürzester Zeit einen Namen
als Schweizer Qualitätsschreiner
gemacht.)
(Jetzt kann er ein Ferienhaus
fast in Eigenregie umbauen.)
Ähm, ich habe ...
... irgendwann letztes Jahr einen
deutschen Makler kennengelernt,
der hier tätig ist
für deutschsprachige Kunden.
Der hat das hier
an Schweizer Kunden verkauft.
Er hat mich empfohlen -
weil deutschsprachig.
Und sie haben mich
im Fernsehen gesehen.
Dann haben wir uns mal getroffen
und es hat gepasst.
Dann habe ich angefangen, für sie
das Ferienhaus hier zu renovieren.
(Markus profitiert jeden Tag
von seiner guten Ausbildung
und staunt ab und zu schon etwas
über die Unterschiede
in der Arbeitsweise
zwischen Schweden und Schweizern.)
Sie sind rustikaler, nicht so fein
wie Schweizer Schreiner.
Schöne Gehrungen
oder schön verarbeitete Oberflächen
findet man nicht so oft.
Es ist eher spartanisch.
Man schaut ... Wie bei den Fenstern.
Die Fenster hier sind alle
etwas schräg und wellig.
In der Schweiz würde man
reklamieren, aber hier sagen sie:
"Entschuldigung, du guckst raus,
nicht auf den Rahmen."
Auf eine Art ist das schön,
sie sind nicht so pingelig.
Andererseits denkst du ...
* Ächzen *
Wenn du versuchst, deinen
Schweizer Kopf hier durchzusetzen,
drehst du durch.
Es geht nicht.
Du musst deine Qualität beibehalten,
aber dieses Laisser-faire,
diese Lockerheit der Schweden
einbauen. Dann geht es gut.
Zu Beginn hatte ich Mühe damit,
mittlerweile ... Ja.
* Tänzelnde Klaviermusik *
Hey, schau, jetzt kannst du
durch den Schnee laufen.
Du hast dir hier eine Nest gebaut,
in das man sich zurückziehen kann,
wenn es draussen kalt ist. - Genau.
Wir haben hier unser Nest und machen
im Winter hier unseren Winterschlaf.
* Beide lachen. *
Macht dir das nichts aus?
Hier draussen
bist du wirklich allein.
(Juna) ... die Schaufel.
- Ja, die Schaufel.
Ich empfinde es als grossen Luxus,
dass ich hier so allein bin.
Ganz ehrlich gesagt.
- Als Luxus?
Ja. Das ist für mich voll Luxus.
Ehrlich? - Ja.
- Warum?
Ich finde, es ist ein Privileg,
in der heutigen Zeit
eine solche Ruhe zu haben.
Ja.
- Ja.
Und eine solche Weite.
(Juna sagte mir beim Frühstück,
sie wolle mir ihre Hühner zeigen.)
Jetzt kommen sie, yeah!
Jetzt können wir rein.
Wohin wollen wir das Futter geben?
Unser Futterplatz
ist total eingeschneit.
Wollen wir es hierhin tun, Juna?
- Mhm.
Dort sollst du es reintun.
- Hier soll ich es reintun?
Kannst du ...
Ich habe geschaut,
ob schon etwas drin ist.
So, jetzt ist gut.
- Wie viele Eier habt ihr hier?
Im Moment
haben wir täglich drei Eier.
Es ist absolut perfekt,
die perfekte Menge.
Aber auf den Frühling möchten wir
vielleicht noch mehr kaufen,
damit unsere Gäste
frische Eier haben können. - Ja.
... auf der Schaufel.
- Oh, gut! Aber nicht aufs Huhn.
Für mich war es wichtig,
auch mit den Müttern in der Region
Kontakt zu haben,
damit Juna auch mal
irgendwo spielen gehen kann.
Das habe ich mittlerweile.
Aber es brauchte viel, man muss
schon ziemlich hartnäckig sein.
Wie hast du das gemacht?
- Nicht aufgegeben.
Also immer wieder telefoniert,
geklingelt? - Nein, nein.
Es gibt natürlich hier diese Treffen
am Morgen, die man besuchen kann,
wo man mit den Kindern spielen geht.
Die ersten paar Male
war es so ein wenig ... Ja.
Man kam nicht gleich auf uns zu.
Vielleicht war ich auch
am falschen Ort.
Es gibt ja
verschiedene Einrichtungen.
Ich habe mir überlegt,
wo ich es noch probieren könnte.
Plötzlich ging es dann.
Ich habe Verschiedenes probiert
an verschiedenen Orten.
Und plötzlich
hatte ich meine Frauen.
Weisst du noch, was wir letztes Jahr
hier gemacht haben, Juna?
Wir haben Schneebälle rübergeworfen.
Gell, bei Papas Tor.
Hier.
* Mona lacht. *
Weisst du noch?
Schau!
Wenn er nach Hause kommt, denkt er:
"Was ist wohl hier passiert?"
Willst du auch mal?
Hier.
Du kannst nach vorne gehen
und ihn hinschmeissen.
Fest!
Oh, super!
Der ging nicht so weit.
(Juna) Nach vorne gehen.
- Also, geh ein wenig nach vorne.
Hui!
- Super!
Jetzt ist es gegangen.
Was heisst "Gar inte finns inte"?
Geht nicht gibt's nicht.
- Ah!
Stark, gell?
- Ja.
Bluffsack!
- Nein, bei Markus ...
Das hast du gesagt.
- Ich darf das, weisst du.
Nach allem,
was ich von Markus gesehen habe ...
Er ist einer der wenigen Menschen,
denen ich das glaube. - Es ist so.
Geht nicht gibt's nicht.
Stand er schon mal irgendwo an?
Kann er irgendetwas nicht?
Er ist schon ein bisschen MacGyver.
Kennst du MacGyver?
- Ja, ja.
Der, der für alles ein Tool hat
und alles kann.
Nein, es gibt schon Dinge,
bei denen er ansteht,
z.B. beim Thema Wasser, Sanitär,
solche Sachen.
Ja. Oder IKEA-Möbel.
Genau. Oder IKEA-Betten.
Das ist jetzt schon ein wenig fies,
dass wir uns so darüber freuen.
Die ganze Schweiz freute sich so,
als der patente Markus
am gleichen Ding scheiterte
wie wir alle.
Ja, gell!
Der gelernte Schreiner
macht sich ans Werk:
schwedische Möbel zusammensetzen.
* Drollige Klänge *
Ja?
- Es fehlt was. Es fehlt was.
Was?
- Ich kann das Bett nicht montieren.
Nein, es geht nicht, Entschuldigung.
- Aber was fehlt denn?
Siehst du die Matratzen?
Die haben abgeschrägte Ecken. - Mhm.
Das ist eine stinknormale Matratze.
Die Matratzen, die wir haben,
heissen auch nicht Lauvik,
die heissen Hamarvik.
- Ja, die habe ich bestellt.
Es hiess, die gingen auch,
seien aber nicht so hart.
Es geht nicht, da fehlt was.
Ah!
Langsam dämmert es Markus.
* Stöhnen *
* Sylvia lacht. *
Oh Mann!
* Stöhnen *
Ja?
Sind die Schienen falsch?
- Ah! Ich kriege Vögel!
Ich glaube, ich habe es gerade ...
Fuck, hey! - Siehst du?
Er hat das Bettgestell
falsch montiert.
Ich habe es bei der Bestellung
etwa 17-Mal kontrolliert.
Das nächste Mal sagst du mir,
dass unser Bett ...
Das ist eine Montageanleitung.
- Hast du es nach ...
Die Montageanleitung ist für
Arnavik, Dunvik und Lauvik.
Ich habe mich einfach
für Arnavik entschieden
anstatt logischerweise für Lauvik.
Aber immer erst
der Frau die Schuld geben.
Ja, natürlich. Wem sonst?
- Darum bin ich so ruhig geblieben.
Ich dachte:
Diesmal kann es nicht an mir liegen.
* Beide lachen. *
Oh Mann!
Ich äussere mich nicht
zu dieser Szene.
Es gibt drei Dinge zu dieser Szene.
Erste Variante: Ich habe grund-
sätzlich IKEA die Schuld gegeben,
nicht Sylvia.
Das ist falsch rübergekommen.
Ich bin davon ausgegangen,
dass sie falsch angeliefert haben.
Zweitens:
Es war nicht falsch montiert,
nur die Richtung der Füsse
war verkehrt.
Nur die Füsse waren verkehrt rum.
- Ah, nur? Okay.
Und ...
- Drittens?
Meine Kollegen fanden so amüsant,
dass ich als Ausstellungsschreiner
bei Möbel Pfister das IKEA-Bett,
die Füsse ...
Aber weisst du, was mich wundert?
Sylvia hat mir erzählt,
dass du den ganzen Sommer
darauf angesprochen wurdest und es
mittlerweile aufgegeben hättest,
dich zu rechtfertigen.
- Ja, aber jetzt kann ich es ...
Doch nicht ganz? - Jetzt
kann ich es  e i n m a l  sagen.
Ihr habt mich ja damit konfrontiert.
- Du warst seine letzte Chance.
Um sich zu rehabilitieren,
deinen Ruf.
Jetzt wird es ausgestrahlt,
man sieht es.
Was heisst, mein Ruf?
- Deinen Ruf wiederherstellen.
Es war grossartig, dass einer, der
Schreiner ist, das auch nicht kann.
Das hat der Seele so vieler Menschen
in der Schweiz so gutgetan.
Aber es ist auch
eine Fehleinschätzung.
Du weisst als Schreiner nicht ...
Egal, bei welchem Möbel: Der, der es
designt hat, hat es so designt,
dass es kleinstmöglich
verpackt wird.
Und nicht,
dass es logisch montiert wird.
Als Schreiner
muss man auch auf das Ding gucken.
Ich fände es arrogant,
als Schreiner zu sagen:
"Ich brauche keine
Montageanleitung." Die braucht man.
Es treibt ihn um.
- Ein wenig schon.
Natürlich ist es peinlich.
- Ein wenig. Aber ich verstehe es.
Ich habe gehört,
dass du all den Schweizern,
die euch hier besucht haben -
und das waren viele -
diese Geschichte erzählen musstest.
Stimmt das?
Ja, und alle meinten,
es sei ein anderes Bett.
"Ist es dieses Bett?" "Nein".
"Dieses?" "Nein".
"Das ist es jetzt. Okay."
Ja, es ist halt ...
Es haben sogar Leute ...
Vielleicht tröstet dich,
dass du nicht der einzige
mit einer solchen Szene warst.
Jede Familie, die ausgewandert ist,
hat so einen Moment,
auf den sie wohl
ihr Leben lang angesprochen werden.
Einige davon sehen wir jetzt.
Huere Siech noch mal,
du elende, verdammte, verreckte Sau!
Gottverdammt!
Geh doch einfach in dieses
verdammte, verreckte Mausloch!
Das ist nicht zu glauben.
Es nervt!
Die Salami ist auch ausgegangen.
Ach je.
Wir improvisieren,
darin sind wir gut.
Heute wollen alle Schinken mit Ei.
Das ist scheisse.
Das Guesthouse
ist seit Kurzem eröffnet.
Das Schinken-und-Ei-Frühstück
wurde bis heute noch nie bestellt.
So, das ist besser.
Morning, boys!
* Lachen *
This is the last one,
now, it's finished.
* Fernöstlich anmutende Zupfmusik *
* Stöhnen *
Scheisse, habe ich vergessen,
den Dings draufzutun? Mmh!
Heute ist nicht gut, was?
- Nein.
Den kannst du nicht geben, Schatz.
Doch.
- Nein.
Hey, shut the fuck up!
Was habe ich zwei Monate lang
gemacht? Gespielt.
Ich darf wohl auch mal anderes tun
als spielen. Spielen! Spielen!
Wir sind schon
freundlich miteinander,
aber wir reden einfach nicht immer
so ... wie die Vorzeigeschweizer.
Genau, so ist es.
Wir reden einfach
anders miteinander.
Eher wie die Australier,
übersetzt auf Deutsch.
Die nennen einander den ganzen Tag
"bloody idiot" und "bugger".
Es ist einfach, wie es ist.
Wenn er in dem Moment ein Idiot ist,
ist er ein Idiot.
Dann kann ich nicht sagen,
er sei ein Blümchen.
Achtung!
Sonst gibt es noch mal eins.
Svensito, pass auf!
Sven! Nicht kaputt machen!
Das ist für Papi!
Auch der kleine Sven kann es kaum
erwarten, dass Papi wieder da ist.
Nur zeigt er seine Vorfreude
auf ein wenig andere Art.
Mira!
Sven, wer kommt heute?
Sven! Nicht kaputt machen!
Hallo?
* Sven schreit und lacht. *
* Sven spricht unverständlich. *
Te gusta? Es para papa.
* Erschrockenes Einatmen *
Sven! Nein! Sven!
Caramba, estoy hiciendolo para papa.
No toques!
Meine Güte, Tibby, dort hinten
läuft Wasser aus einer Leitung.
Wo?
- Hier hinten.
Ich mache mir in die Hose.
Das fliesst aus der Wand.
Hä? - Let's take this thing out,
quickly.
Ein Thema
zieht sich wie ein roter Faden
durch die Auswanderergeschichten:
Wasserrohrbrüche
rund um den Erdball!
Kann ich helfen, Tibby?
- Nein. Ich wüsste nicht, was.
Vielleicht das Wasser ausschalten.
Das ist
eine total falsche Installation.
Mhm.
Die eh geplante Sanierung
des Badezimmers
hat nun oberste Priorität!
* Lachen *
It is!
Ooh! Yeah,
there's something wrong out here.
Horrible.
I mean, it is like ...
I don't know.
* Lachen *
Meine ganze Küche
steht unter Wasser.
Sie ist noch nicht mal montiert.
* Seufzen *
Ich weiss nicht,
was für Material die verkaufen.
Dieser Scheissdreck ist verdammt
noch mal einen Monat dicht.
Von einer Nacht auf die andere
ist er geplatzt.
Frag mich nicht, warum.
Ich habe nichts daran gemacht.
Das ist einfach eine Scheissmarke.
Das ist der dritte, der kaputtgeht.
Es ist immer die gleiche Marke.
Ich werde alles von dieser
Scheissmarke auswechseln.
Ich habe die Schnauze voll.
Ein Wasserrohr ist geborsten -
direkt vor der Hoteltür.
Oh mein Gott!
Das ist ja unglaublich.
Sie haben wohl beim Öffnen
irgendwo eine Leitung angeknackt.
Wieder muss Monika warten.
Und diese Warterei
erträgt sie kaum mehr.
Man sollte vorwärtsmachen und
dann passieren so komische Sachen.
Manchmal
könnte man einfach nur losheulen.
Feuerwehr ist da!
* Einzelne lange Gitarrenklänge *
Hier stinkt's.
- Mhm.
Ich rieche was.
Vielleicht ist es das verstopfte.
Wie kann das sein?
Als würde es
vom Abwasserschacht reindrücken.
Hier haben Christian
und sein Mitarbeiter Mirko
vor Kurzem den Wohnwagen
an die Abwasserleitung angeschlossen.
Tatü, tata!
- Ah!
Papi, was ist?
Ich glaube,
ich habe herausgefunden, was. - Was?
Ihr seid Helden, jetzt
fliesst es ab. Was hast du gemacht?
Wir haben den Schlauch
zu weit hinunter gesteckt,
als wir
Mirkos Trailer angehängt haben.
Mmh, ist das lecker!
Wir haben es schon.
Und das werfen wir rein, oder?
- Hm?
Das werfen wir rein?
- Du kannst, wenn du willst.
Ja, gerne, aber nicht mit den
Händen. Ich hole die Schaufel.
Gion! Du hast einen grossen Stink
gemacht. Jetzt hat es ihn verklemmt.
Nein.
- Nicht? Doch!
Gell, Mami? - Nein, Gion.
Das war nicht dein grosser Stink.
Das war die Dummheit
von Mirko und Papa.
Ja, ja!
- Ja!
Komm, ich mach's.
- Aber kein Dreck, gell.
Das ist kein Dreck.
Igitt.
Das sind so diese Momente.
- Ja.
So was ist zum Glück nicht passiert,
oder?
Bei uns wirklich nicht,
auch neben der Kamera nicht, oder?
Gleich so heftig.
- Nein.
Aber was man hier sieht
und was bei vielen so ist:
Solange man darüber lachen kann ...
Man darf einfach irgendwie
den Humor nicht verlieren. - Ja.
Dann hast du verloren.
Wer von euch ist
der schonungslosere Optimist?
Wer zweifelt ...
Er?
Optimismus auf dieser Seite.
Bei dir eher wieder mal Zweifel?
- Nein, nur noch Zweifel - damals.
Es war dann ...
In dieser Phase ...
Wenn man natürlich schwanger ist
und dabei ist,
eine Familie zu gründen
und so viele Unsicherheiten da sind,
macht einem das manchmal auch Angst.
Dass wirklich alles zusammenbricht
und man vor dem Nichts steht.
Ja, man hat Existenzängste.
Ich bin ...
Es war Markus, der mich
in dieser Zeit getragen hat -
oder mitgeschleppt.
Das kann man sagen.
Ja.
- Ja.
Ich hatte auch die Möglichkeit,
mich darauf vorzubereiten.
Ich habe Kurse besucht,
Mentaltraining gemacht
zu positivem Denken.
Ich habe mir wie ein ...
Ich weiss nicht ...
Durchgeknallt.
Ich habe mir immer eingetrichtert,
bis zum Gehtnichtmehr:
Es wird alles gut,
es funktioniert alles,
es gibt keine Frühgeburt,
es geht nichts kaputt.
Wie ein Mantra.
- Ja.
Sodass ich selbst ab und zu dachte:
Jetzt schneit's bei den Elchen.
Ich habe mir selbst Dinge
eingetrichtert, einfach nur so.
Das ist ...
Ich glaube ... Eben.
Es war eine spezielle Zeit.
- Ja.
Ich glaube,
das macht am Schluss ganz viel aus,
auch wenn man
bei anderen Auswanderern schaut:
Wie man mit dem umgeht,
das man nicht beeinflussen kann.
Viele sind super vorbereitet,
wie wir Schweizer es eben sind.
Man richtet sich auf alles ein,
aber oft kommt es ganz anders.
Z.B. Volks, die wir gesehen haben,
mussten so lange kämpfen,
bis sie endlich ihre
permanent residency bekommen haben,
also die Bewilligung,
in Kanada bleiben zu dürfen.
Als es dann endlich so weit war,
hatten wir alle das Gefühl:
Jetzt ist der Mist geführt,
alles ist so, wie es sein muss.
Aber jetzt gibt es bei Volks
wieder Neuigkeiten.
Zum einen eine gute,
zum anderen aber eine,
die sie deutlich weniger freut.
Hallo zusammen, hallo!
- Hallo.
Hallo miteinander!
- Hallo!
Ja, es hat sich einiges verändert
seit letztem September.
Vielleicht willst du ...
Das Positive ist unsere Leeza.
Sie wächst und gedeiht
und rennt umher, hält uns auf Trab.
Und vom Geschäftlichen her,
bei der Firma:
Die ganze Holzwirtschaft
in British Columbia ist gecrasht.
Wir sind eigentlich ...
Im Winter
waren wir zehn Festangestellte,
jetzt arbeite ich noch allein
mit einer Maschine.
Alles andere,
all die neuen Maschinen und
Investments sind wieder verkauft.
Die Arbeiter sind irgendwo anders.
(Wir erinnern uns:
Volks haben sich aufgemacht,
den kanadischen Baum
das Fürchten zu lernen.)
(Mit Spezialmaschinen
hat Christian Volk in Kanada
erfolgreich
in der Holzwirtschaft mitgespielt
und ein eigenes Unternehmen
aufgebaut.)
(Bis die Hiobsbotschaft kam.)
Im Winter sagte unser Sägereichef:
"The party is over."
Der Holzmarkt ist innerhalb
von zwei, drei Monaten gecrasht.
Das hatte zur Folge,
dass in der ganzen Provinz
bei Sägereien der Einschnitt
gestoppt wurde,
aber auch Werke abgestellt wurden.
Und in unserem Fall wurde das Werk
komplett abgestellt, für immer.
Es wird nie wieder angeschaltet.
Ich wäre sofort wieder zurück.
Ich würde auch jetzt zurückgehen.
Aber auch in der Schweiz
fangen wir wieder bei Null an.
Und dort ist es im Moment in der
Holzwirtschaft auch nicht einfach.
Und hier alles aufgeben ...
Man ist ja doch auch aus einem Grund
hierher gekommen.
Vieles, das wir hier haben,
wie unsere Tiere und unser Land,
haben wir in der Schweiz auch nicht.
Es wäre ein über...
Wie sagt man?
Ein übereifriger ...
Ja, ein Übereifer gewesen,
zu sagen: "Wir gehen zurück."
Am Anfang dachten wir:
"Super, was machen wir jetzt?"
Man muss ja etwas machen.
Wir waren absolut planlos.
Dann hatten wir ein paar Ideen,
aber bei jeder fand man
aus irgendwelchen Gründen:
Das funktioniert nicht
und das auch nicht.
Mittlerweile haben wir einen Plan.
Das macht es auch wieder positiver.
Jetzt wissen wir wenigstens,
wie es weitergeht.
So packen wir es noch mal an
und probieren es halt noch mal.
Wir fangen wieder von vorne an.
- Nicht gerade.
Ein Stück weit.
Ganz von vorne nicht,
aber wieder etwas Neues.
Das ist nichts Neues, wir machen
dasselbe, einfach kleiner. - Ja, du!
Bei der Firma
werde ich für mich allein,
mit der Maschine, die ich noch habe,
mit dieser Winde
Steilhangfällen machen.
Spezialarbeiten. - Spezialarbeiten
für andere Unternehmer.
Oder für den Staat,
ist dann später die Idee,
entlang von Stromleitungen,
Pipelines ... Ja.
Aber schlussendlich
haben wir jetzt ...
Vielleicht haben wir jetzt das,
was wir wollen.
Wir haben jetzt Kühe,
kriegen noch mehr Kühe,
wollen vielleicht etwas
in Richtung Tourismus machen.
Ja. Mal schauen.
- Ja.
Nein, ich denke, es funktioniert
schon gut. Oder? - Genau.
Schönen Gruss an die Schweiz.
Tschüss. - Tschüss.
(Wenn wir Auswanderer bei ihren
Abenteuern begleiten, heisst das,
dass wir auch private und
beinahe intime Situationen zeigen.)
(Und die ganze Schweiz
schaut dabei zu.)
(Das kann durchaus Konsequenzen
haben für unsere Protagonisten.)
(Schöne
und manchmal auch etwas mühsame.)
Wie muss man es sich vorstellen,
wenn man im Fernsehen kommt
und plötzlich zur Attraktion wird?
Das war schon etwas befremdend.
Wir waren sehr überrascht darüber,
wie nachhaltig die Reaktionen sind.
Wir dachten: "Ja, Fernsehen,
nach zwei Monaten
spricht kein Mensch mehr davon."
"Das ist alles so kurzlebig."
Und trotzdem sind wir erstaunt,
wie lange die Reaktionen anhalten.
Ja.
Welche Reaktionen habt ihr bekommen?
Am Anfang war es merkwürdig,
dass jemand schreibt:
"He, toll, Glückwünsch,
Gratulation."
Oder: "Hätten wir in jungen Jahren
auch gerne gemacht."
Und dann gab es viele,
die hergefahren sind,
an die Türe geklopft und gesagt
haben: "Hallo zusammen." - Ehrlich?
Am Anfang kam da
mal einer zum Kaffeetrinken,
dann zweimal, dann dreimal,
dann wurden es immer mehr.
Leider war ab und zu jemand arg ...
... aufdringlich.
Irgendwann haben wir gemerkt,
dass wir nicht ständig
mit jemandem Kaffee trinken können.
Es geht nicht nur um uns,
sondern auch um die Menschen,
die unsere Ferienhäuser mieten.
Dass die ihre Ruhe haben.
Wenn ständig jemand mit der
Handykamera übers Grundstück läuft,
ist das etwas schwierig.
D.h., ihr seid eine fixe
Sehenswürdigkeit in der Gegend?
Ja, nebst Astrid Lindgren.
- Genau.
Danach kommen sofort wir -
für die Schweizer.
Da ist die Schreinerei ...
(Sylvia und Markus scheinen auch
mit dieser Situation gut umzugehen.)
... zu sehen gibt.
- Bitte schön.
Das ist der Part,
der ausgebaut werden sollte.
Sollte?
- Ja.
Du brauchst deine Maschinen
ja tatsächlich zum Arbeiten.
Das verbindet dich mit den meisten
Männern, die ausgewandert sind.
Kaum waren sie ausgewandert,
kauften sie sich irgend ein Gadget.
Spielzeug.
Ja, irgendein spezielles Fahrzeug
gekauft.
Du auch, oder?
- Ne.
Doch, du hast doch
diesen super Rasenmäher ...
Na, der bereitet ihr mehr Freude
als mir.
Also ...
Nein, ehrlich?
Oder?
Er bereitet uns beiden Freude.
- Ja.
Das ist Markus' neues Spielzeug.
Hey!
Ein Rasenmäher. Natürlich ein
Aufsitzmäher. Mit Allradantrieb.
Schön, oder? Willst du
ihn ausprobieren? - Du?
Machen wir eine Testfahrt. Judihui!
Ich mache später eine.
Ohne 4 x 4 ging's nicht.
Ach, läuft der schön.
Die Steigungen auf dem Gelände
wollen bezwungen werden.
Wie er strahlt.
- Schön, ah.
* Beschwingte glockige Klänge *
Als wäre es ein Naturgesetz:
Männer und ihre Maschinen.
Gib mal Gas.
- Wo?
Am orangen Ding.
- Hier?
* Der Motor stottert. *
Was einen Motor hat und mit Benzin
läuft, ist immer genial.
So.
* Der Motor startet. *
* Der Motor stottert. *
Der wird denken ...
Vielleicht das Ding ...
Vielleicht hier mit on/off? Auf 1?
- Ja, auf 1. Hast du?
Das war auf 0 die ganze Zeit.
- Dann ist es klar.
Okay.
Gas geben.
How far are you with the car?
The car is ready?
Yeah. If you go down ...
Then I can check the car out, now?
That would be great.
Auch Mike Wiedmer
hat sich für ein paar Extra-
Pferdestärken in Rot entschieden.
Ja, macht einen guten Eindruck.
Sieht cool aus. Wird was.
Die Scheiben
hätte ich gerne etwas dunkler,
aber wir nehmen ihn so.
Das kann man dann selber machen.
* Der Motor läuft. *
Zu klein.
Ich stell's mal ab.
Es ist zu eng eingestellt.
Wer hat den vorhin getragen?
* Piepen *
* Ein Hund bellt. *
* Winseln *
Das ist Musik, oder?
Ja, und zuerst raucht er mega.
Stimmt. Das ist wichtig -
dass es raucht.
Dann weiss man, dass es läuft.
Wo Lärm und Rauch sind,
ist Kraft.
* Unverständlich *
Wo mache ich das?
- Da ist ein Hebel.
Was mache ich damit?
- Rauf.
Rauf?
Ich weiss nicht, was es ist.
* Unverständlich *
* Der Motor verstummt. *
Anja, du hast es falsch gemacht.
- Ach, Mann!
* Entspannte rockige Klänge *
Endlich steht der Arbeit
nichts mehr im Weg.
Oder besser gesagt: fast nichts.
* Der Motor verstummt. *
Ah.
- Kaputt.
Hätte nicht ausschalten müssen.
- Maschine kaputt.
Nein, aber da sind so viele Dornen,
da verhedderst du dich richtig.
# U sie stigen i Flüger,
flüge mit de Vögu furt,
# chöme nümme hei.
Uf u drvo.
(In Snokebo
scheint die Sonne im Winter selten.)
(Und wenn, dann nur kurz.)
(Es ist deshalb
ein doppelter Genuss,
durch dieses kleine Paradies
zu spazieren,
das Sylvia und Markus
hier geschaffen haben.)
Hereinspaziert.
(Ganz ohne Meinungsverschiedenheiten
ging es aber auch bei ihnen nicht.)
Ja. - Ich muss mich hier
etwas aufwärmen.
Was ist hier alles neu?
Eigentlich nicht viel:
Wände, Tapete,
Farbe und halt Möbel,
die Inneneinrichtung.
Das haben wir komplett rausgenommen.
- Ja.
Und ... die heissgeliebte Decke.
Es gibt eine Geschichte zur Decke,
oder?
Ja.
Einer von Hunderten
von Kompromissen.
Also, was Kompromiss?
Wir wussten beide, dass wir
die Decke weiss streichen müssen.
Nur wollte ich einfach nicht.
Aber du wusstet,
dass es sein musste. - Ja.
Aber du wolltest nicht.
- Es gibt nichts ...
Die ganze Schweiz denkt jetzt,
ich sei eine richtige Hexe.
Vielleicht müssen wir es einfach
nochmals miteinander anschauen.
Damit man das nachempfinden kann.
Pippa, gehen wir baden?
Komm!
In Snokebo sind die Buobs
voller Tatendrang.
Schon bald wollen sie
hier Ferienwohnungen vermieten.
Jetzt wird's interessant.
Wir möchten den Raum aufhellen.
Die Diskussion ist ...
Ich wäre dafür, dass wir
die Decke kalken oder lasieren.
Damit sie auch hell wird.
Markus sagt, die Decke lassen wir in
Holz, damit es mehr Kontrast gibt.
Kann ich sagen,
was ich machen möchte?
Wir sollten zuerst das machen
und schauen, wie's wird.
Theoretisch kann man das ja.
- Praktisch auch.
Ich finde, der Raum
ist zu klein für den Kontrast,
den du dir vorstellst.
- Nein.
Die Fenster sind so klein,
wir müssen für so viel Helligkeit
wie möglich sorgen.
Aber ich möchte es
auch nicht zu weiss machen.
Nein. Es wird nie zu weiss.
Denn der Boden bleibt immer Holz.
Die Decke würden wir nur lasieren.
Wir würden
die Holzstruktur behalten.
Klar würden wir sie behalten,
aber ...
Können wir nicht ...
- Doch, wir machen den Kompromiss.
Gut.
Ist es ein Kompromiss,
wenn am Schluss Sylvia sagt,
was ihr macht?
- Das ist der Kompromiss.
Ist es in etwa so?
Darf ich reden?
- Ja.
Okay.
(Zögernd) Jein.
Nein, es war einfach -
jener Kompromiss ...
Ich wusste, dass man streichen
müsste, hatte aber keine Lust.
Ich habe da
die anderen Sachen gesehen:
die Tapete runternehmen
und die andere anbringen,
die Küche machen.
Was haben wir noch gemacht?
Die ganzen Möbel.
Und in dem Moment dachte ich: "Ach,
diese Decke muss jetzt nicht sein."
Die musste sein.
- Für dich, oder?
Ja, ich ...
- Für mich auch.
Ich wusste, wie diese Häuser
am Schluss aussehen müssen.
Das musste einfach kompromisslos
durchgeführt werden.
* Sylvia lacht. *
Hattet ihr während dieser
stressigen Zeit viele Diskussionen?
Extrem.
Und Hunderte von Entscheidungen.
Wir diskutieren immer noch.
- Natürlich.
Es gibt so viele Dinge,
die du entscheiden musst.
Aber ich glaube,
in Sachen Umbau war das das einzige,
wo wir nicht gleicher Meinung waren.
Nein, Markus.
Wir haben uns so oft gezankt.
Auswandern ist
ein totaler Beziehungstest, oder?
Total, es ist kein Spaziergang.
- Ja.
Das ist so.
Aber es ist bei uns gut gegangen -
bis jetzt.
Das denke ich wirklich,
wenn ich diese Paare sehe.
Man steht
vor so vielen Herausforderungen,
man ist total unter Druck.
Von aussen wie von innen.
Wenn man es da
als Paar nicht gut hat,
dann explodiert man.
- Ja, das ist so.
Das ist so.
Es muss einem auch bewusst sein:
Man geht nicht nur als Paar,
sondern irgendwie auch als Team.
Jeder muss sich auch irgendwie
auf eine Art zurücknehmen.
Und ein Ziel suchen.
Man ist wie ein Team,
das ein Ziel hat.
Dann muss man sich ...
Die Beziehung
musste einfach funktionieren.
Das war damals
eine Art Nebenprodukt.
Dass ihr noch ein Paar seid?
- Ja.
Es musste einfach sein.
Wir konnten
in der Zeit der Auswanderung
nicht noch gross
Beziehungspflege machen.
Vielleicht war es auch gut,
dass man manchmal nicht so viel Zeit
zum Studieren hatte.
Wir haben vorher bewusst darüber
geredet: "Wie streiten wir?" - Ja.
Ganz einfach.
- Wir wussten, dass ...
Wir wussten,
dass wir streiten würden.
Es gibt Situationen,
in denen man nicht mehr kann
und nervlich ganz dünn ist.
Aber man muss einfach
den Respekt füreinander wahren.
Schlussendlich hat es uns als Paar
stärker gemacht. - Das sicher.
Ich denke,
wir sind als gestärktes Team
aus dieser ganzen
Auswanderungsgeschichte gekommen.
* Sanfte, glockige Klänge *
(Sylvia und Markus
haben also die erste Bewährungsprobe
als Auswandererpaar
bravourös gemeistert.)
(Von anderen Auswanderern
wissen wir,
dass aber auch Jahre
nach dem Auswandern
noch die eine oder andere Prüfung
warten kann.)
Als wir
für "Auf und davon - Souvenirs"
bei unseren Auswanderern
nachgefragt haben,
wie es ihnen so geht,
haben sich auch Buholzers aus Kreta
bei uns gemeldet.
Trix hat uns per Mail geschrieben,
es habe sich nichts gross verändert,
ausser: Champ habe vor einem Jahr
seine Bar verkauft,
sie selbst
habe gesundheitliche Probleme,
ein Bein sei halb gelähmt,
und Marcel sei im Spital gewesen
für einen Bypass.
Wir dachten: "Da fragen wir
vielleicht besser genauer nach!"
Ich hatte Ende Oktober
eine kleine Blasenoperation.
Wir entschieden uns
für eine PDA in den Rücken.
Der Narkosearzt
hat den Nerv getroffen.
Mein Bein war vier Monate lang
komplett gelähmt.
Ich war vier Monate lang
nur im Bett.
Zehn Wochen Thrombose,
sechs Wochen Spital, Katheter ...
Einfach alles,
was man sich nur vorstellen kann.
Die Zehen
funktionieren nach wie vor nicht.
Der Fuss unten auch nicht und
das Knie auch noch nicht richtig.
Es ist eher
ein Nachschleifen des Beins.
Ja, es ...
Man kann lange weinen -
es ist einfach so.
Das ist so.
- Aber es gibt eine Gefahr weniger:
eine Frau weniger auf der Strasse.
Sie kann nicht Auto fahren.
Meine Herzinfarkte
erlitt ich ja in der Schweiz.
Hier hat sich dann ergeben,
dass die Hauptarterie,
die von der Brust
in den Bauch und die Beine geht -
der Verteiler - verstopft war.
Also musste ich im Spital
einen Bypass machen lassen,
resp. ...
Das ist etwa so ...
40 cm Röhre ersetzen.
Durch die Operation
ist es sensationell.
Jetzt bin ich wieder voller Power.
Ja, ja,
unten haben sie nichts weggenommen.
Da musst du durch - aufgeben,
nur weil du ein Wehwehchen hast,
bringt auch nichts.
Na ja, nur ein Wehwehchen
ist es nicht gerade.
Aber es ist so:
Ich habe im Spital
auch Sachen erlebt, die ...
Da bin ich noch gut dran.
Deshalb sagte ich: Es gibt
viel Schlimmeres auf der Welt
als dass mein Bein nicht mehr
funktioniert, wie es sollte.
In der Schweiz ging es damals schon
los wegen meiner Infarkte usw.
Es hiess,
ich sollte es ruhiger angehen.
Auch hier ging ich weiterhin
jedes Jahr in die Kontrolle.
Auch hier
sagte man mir mit der Zeit,
ich solle Sorge zu mir tragen,
etwas herunterfahren und, und, und.
Dann habe ich Trix vorgeschlagen,
die Bar zu verkaufen.
Es schmerzt auch jetzt noch.
- Ja, es wurmt ihn sehr.
Vielleicht ist es gut,
dass wir nach Sisi gezogen sind
und nicht mehr in Agios sind.
Man muss einfach
das Positive sehen:
Man macht eine Lebenserfahrung,
etwas,
das andere nicht machen konnten.
Klar gab es Negatives.
Im ganzen Leben
gibt es Negatives und Positives.
Aber sogar im schlimmsten Negativen
gibt es etwas Positives.
Denn auch dort
gibt es irgendeinen Punkt,
den man mitnehmen kann
und mit dem man das Leben geniessen,
verbessern oder verändern kann.
Wenn man nur negativ denkt, gibt man
sich am besten schon früh die Kugel.
Okay!
* Tonausfall *
Danke! Tschüss zusammen!
- Tschüss!
(Wer auswandert,
muss weit vorausschauen können.)
(Schliesslich
möchten die meisten Auswanderer
am neuen Ort
zusammen alt und glücklich werden.)
(Deshalb
kommt es eben schon darauf an,
für welches Land, für welche Kultur
und auch für welches Gesundheits-
system man sich entscheidet.)
Warum wurde es bei euch
eigentlich Schweden?
War das schon immer klar?
- Nein, absolut nicht.
Es war überhaupt keine
romantische Entscheidung,
nach Schweden zu gehen.
- Nein.
Nicht? Obwohl man das Gefühl hat ...
- Ja, ja ...
Man stellt sich vor, dass das
schon immer unser Traum war.
Aber es war überhaupt nicht so.
Wir gingen eigentlich umgekehrt vor.
Wir überlegten uns zuerst,
wie wir leben wollen. - Ja.
Und wie unser Alltag aussehen soll.
Aufgrund dessen schauten wir:
Welches Land
bietet uns die Möglichkeit ...
... das umzusetzen.
- ... das umzusetzen, ja.
Ich glaube, viele finden
Skandinavien deshalb gut,
weil man das Gefühl hat, es sei
relativ ähnlich wie die Schweiz.
War für euch ein Argument, nicht in
eine total andere Kultur zu wollen?
Es ist ja interessant, dass man als
Mitteleuropäer immer das Gefühl hat,
dass die Skandinavier - oder ich
kann nur von den Schweden reden -
recht ähnlich seien wie wir.
- Ja.
Denn sie sehen gleich aus.
Aber es ist eben nicht so.
Sie sind schon sehr eigen hier.
- Eigen?
Mhm.
- Mhm.
Wie? Verschlossener als wir?
Wir Schweizer gelten ja schon eher
als kontrolliert und distanziert.
Ja. - Ja.
- Die Schweden?
Die Schweden sind da
schon etwas lockerer drauf. - Ja.
Sehr locker manchmal.
- Okay.
Man kommt einfacher in ein Gespräch,
ist automatisch per Du.
Ja.
- Per Sie gibt es nicht.
Zum Kennenlernen
ist das ziemlich praktisch.
Es geht nicht ums Siezen, Duzen,
sondern ist einfach klar.
Wo musstet ihr euch anpassen?
Ich würde sagen, wir beide neigen
schon eher zum Perfektionismus.
Ja. Und der Schwede nicht.
- Und die Schweden nicht.
Dort sind wir noch dabei,
Kompromisse zu finden.
Am Ende spielt es gar keine Rolle,
in welches Land man auswandert.
Irgendeine Anpassung
an eine andere Kultur
mussten wohl all unsere
Auswanderer/-innen machen.
Wie hat sie das gemacht?
Sonst machst du es halt ähnlich
wie beim Dings.
Du hast ja auch einen Gürtel dazu.
Und irgendwo hier hinten? Und der
Gürtel müsste eine Schlaufe haben?
Ich denke so. Oder?
- Ja.
Wir haben es doch. Ist gut?
Andere Länder, andere Sitten -
landestypische Rituale
und religiöse Zeremonien
stellen
für unsere Schweizer Auswanderer
regelmässig
echte Herausforderungen dar.
* Verspielte
exotische Glockenklänge *
* Schnelle, glockige Klänge *
Auch Anni Kuhn und Orlando Stamm
haben auf Bali das ganze Dorf
zu einer farbenfrohen
Einweihungszeremonie eingeladen.
Den genauen Zweck dieser Rituale
zu beschreiben,
fällt jedoch
nicht immer ganz leicht.
* Er spricht
in einer fremden Sprache. *
Hier ist jetzt der Platz,
an dem alles geweiht ist
und alles Böse weg ist.
... dass Gäste willkommen sind.
- Genau.
Also einfach das Land ...
Das ist jetzt der Glaube
und wir bekamen etwas zu essen.
Hier hat es noch etwas.
- Alle Häuschen sind jetzt gesegnet.
... dass alles im Einklag
mit Gut und Schlecht sein soll.
Genau.
- Dass die Balance stimmen sollte.
Es wäre eigentlich bereit
fürs Business. - Ja.
... dass die Gäste kommen. Wir
lassen natürlich nichts unversucht.
Nein!
Heute ist eben der glückliche Tag.
- Der Schutz der Götter ist ...
... ist gewährleistet.
Das ist sehr wichtig für ...
Das Böse kann nicht mehr rein
und das Gute ...
... geht nicht mehr raus.
- Geht nicht mehr raus.
Gratis ist der Segen der Götter
freilich nicht.
Okay. Thank you very much.
Neben religiösen Eigenheiten
sind hin und wieder auch
Essensgewohnheiten samt Zubereitung
gewöhnungsbedürftig.
Anni Kuhn und Orlando Stamm
bietet sich an diesem Tag
ein besonderes Schauspiel:
In einem Hinterhof
werden Unmengen an Opfergaben
für das grosse Eröffnungsfest
vorbereitet.
* Leise Gespräche *
Ich glaube, ich muss gehen.
Mir wird es übel.
Ich muss irgendwie ...
Aber sicher!
Schau mal: der Pinsel, den er hat!
Man kann ja nicht sagen,
man wolle nichts.
Ich muss einfach
irgendeine Tasche mitnehmen,
damit ich es
in die Tasche legen kann.
Mmh, smells good!
Mmh! Hühnerfüsse! Desiree!
Famous. Later.
- Later.
Schau jetzt. Bei den Hühnerfüssen
nimmt man zuerst die Finger.
Nein. Later.
* Eine Katze miaut. *
Mmh! Good!
In Thailand
haben Lanee und Hans-Jörg Jäger
ungebetene Gäste auf ihrer Baustelle.
Oh! Die Kuh ging auch rein.
Wer grossen Wert
auf helvetische Gepflogenheiten
auf der Baustelle legt,
sollte sich das Auswandern
gut überlegen.
Mein Schwiegervater
hat die Kühe hier eingesperrt.
Ich sehe es natürlich
gar nicht gerne,
wenn diese mir
auf den Boden des Betons urinieren.
Dann habe ich Harnsäure im Beton,
die ich nicht mehr rausbringe.
Heute ist niemand hier,
um zu arbeiten.
Den Kühen ist heiss.
Deshalb stehen sie unter dem Hotel.
Wenn das Hotel fertig ist,
dürfen die Kühe nicht mehr kommen.
Aber jetzt
können sie das Hotel auch besuchen.
Sie sind aber süss.
Das gibt Dünger.
Ja ...
Das geht nicht.
* Lanee lacht. *
Schade, habe ich keine Kamera dabei.
- Ha, ha, ha!
Ich könnte deiner Tochter
ein Foto schicken,
wie der Vater Scheisse aufräumt.
Es braucht gar nicht immer Kühe,
um sichtbar zu machen,
dass auf manchen Baustellen
dieser Welt andere Massstäbe gelten.
Aber sind die Fenster
nicht zu weit oben?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Der Keller ist ziemlich tief,
das habe ich gestern schon gedacht.
Die Decke wird ziemlich hoch sein,
wenn ich es so anschaue.
Der Keller scheint zu tief zu sein,
entsprechend sind die Fenster
zu hoch gesetzt.
Das wäre ein Desaster,
denn im Keller ihres Hotels
wollen die beiden künftig wohnen.
Wenn ich die Pläne anschaue,
sieht es nicht so hoch aus.
Dort ist die Höhe normal.
- Es wird wie im Plan sein.
Wie die anderen Zimmer.
Bertan konsultiert
die Baupläne auf seinem Handy.
2,65 m ist es.
- Nein, das ist viel mehr.
Schau mal,
wie gross die Arbeiter sind.
Die sind nicht sehr gross.
Der ist vielleicht
sogar kleiner als du,
der, der sich momentan
dort beschäftigt.
Die sind körperlich nicht so gross.
* Gemächliche Tangomusik *
Wie man sich bettet, so liegt man,
sagt das Sprichwort.
Nur scheint das keine
mexikanische Redensart zu sein.
E questa e l'entrata.
Molto piccoli, ma pero funzionali.
Gute Idee!
- So kann man das Bett nicht klauen.
Si, qui per qualsiasi ...
- Non va. Non e possibile cosi.
Wenn du das Bett klauen willst,
musst du es rausspitzen.
Ah!
* Lachen *
Bevor die Auswanderer den
ersten Spatenstich machen können,
stehen schwierige Kaufverhandlungen
bevor.
Nicht immer gilt
das einst gesprochene Wort.
Die Anwältin
begrüsst Claudio überschwänglich.
Claudio ist blendend gelaunt -
noch.
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Siehst du?
* Lachen *
Das ist jetzt ... Was?
Kontakt haben mit den Leuten,
dann klappt es.
Gar nichts klappt.
In der Kanzlei erwartet sie
kein unterschriftsfertiger Vertrag.
Und auch der abgemachte Preis
gilt plötzlich nicht mehr.
* Sie sprechen spanisch. *
Statt 73 Mio. will sie jetzt 85 Mio.
Wir haben letztes Jahr
ja schon die Anzahlung gemacht.
3'500 Fr. mehr.
- 3'500?
No se.
Hier wird viel geredet
und wenig gemacht.
Solange du etwas von ihnen brauchst,
sind sie am längeren Hebel.
Unverrichteter Dinge
ziehen Claudio und Teres ab.
Platzt bereits jetzt
der Traum vom eigenen Haus?
Wir zahlen jetzt das Dreifache
des Preises ...
Nicht unbedingt.
Wir machen uns mal schlau.
Dreimal mehr
als ursprünglich abgemacht -
das sind 60'000 Fr.
So viel müssen die beiden
für ihr Grundstück bezahlen.
Die Anwältin, diese Ziege,
will nicht, dass wir filmen.
* Rhythmische Gitarren-
und Trommelklänge *
Heute wollen Marcel und Trix
die Weichen für ihr neues Leben
stellen.
In ihrer Tasche verwahrt Trix dafür
ein dickes Bündel Scheine.
So, jetzt geht es bergauf.
Ganz, ganz viel Geld.
So viel Geld hatte ich mein Leben
lang noch nie in den Händen.
* Marcel lacht. *
Für mich ist es der Horror,
das übergeben zu müssen.
Das ist ... Nein,
das kann ich fast nicht rausnehmen.
Neben dem Brot, schau!
Ganz viel Geld.
Wir stecken es schnell wieder rein.
Bis ich noch überfallen werde.
Lange hast du es nicht mehr.
- Ja, eben nicht.
Du bist es schon bald los.
- Das stimmt.
Mit dem Geld geht's zum Anwalt.
Dort unterzeichnen Marcel und Trix
den Pachtvertrag.
Good morning.
- Kalimera.
Kalimera.
- Kalimera. Hello!
Der Anwalt erwartet das Ehepaar
bereits im Büro in seinem Wohnhaus.
Ich bin die beste Bank.
* Lachen *
One ... two ...
Das Geld bekommt
der Vorbesitzer der Bar als Ablöse.
Für das Inventar
müssen sie 40'000 Euro bezahlen.
* Stöhnen *
Wahnsinnig viel Geld!
Ich hoffe immer noch,
es sei gut angelegt.
Ich darf gar nicht hinsehen.
* Entspannte Gitarren-
und Schlagzeugmusik *
(Es ist Wochenende.)
(Sylvia und Markus rufen
die Eltern Buob in der Schweiz an.)
(Juna möchte
ihren Grosseltern erzählen,
dass sie einen Gubbar,
einen Schneemann gebaut hat.)
Hallo, hallo.
- Hey, hoi.
* Juna spricht unverständlich. *
Ein Gubbar.
- Hoi!
Hallo!
- Hallo zusammen.
Hallo miteinander.
Wir sind eben auch noch hier.
Wir dachten,
wir möchten euch auch gern sehen,
um zu wissen, wie das für euch ist,
dass die hier
nach Schweden ausgewandert sind.
Für uns ist natürlich mega schön,
dass es ihnen so gut geht
und gefällt.
Aber es tut auch mega weh,
dass sie nicht hier sind.
- Immer noch?
Ja, immer mehr.
- Ich finde, immer mehr, ja.
Immer mehr?
Ja, wegen der Grosskinder natürlich,
Juna, Paula.
Der Schwiegersohn.
* Lachen *
Was denkt ihr?
Werden sie irgendwann zurückkehren
oder ist es endgültig,
dass sie in Schweden sind?
Ach ...
- Jedes Mal, wenn ich oben bin ...
Am Anfang dachte ich immer,
sie kommen bald wieder.
Aber wenn wir jetzt oben sind
und sehen, mit wie viel Freude
und wie sie auf Details Wert legen
und alles schön machen ...
... befürchte ich etwas,
dass sie länger bleiben.
* Sylvia lacht. *
Ich glaube auch, dass es
wirklich endgültig ist. - Ja.
Aber wir werden uns so organisieren,
dass sie vielleicht -
wenn die Kinder grösser sind -
auch ab und zu
in die Schweiz kommen.
Oder dass ihr vielleicht auswandert.
- Genau!
Genau.
- Wir haben hier auch Grosskinder.
Tschau miteinander.
- Alles Gute.
Gute Zeit.
- Tschüss.
Danke. Tschau.
Wenn du deine Eltern siehst - hast
du manchmal ein schlechtes Gewissen?
Weil du denkst, du enthältst ihnen
die Enkelkinder vor? - Nein.
Ich glaube, man muss
kein schlechtes Gewissen haben,
wenn man seinen Weg geht
und seinen Träumen folgt.
Das ist das, was wir getan habe.
Ich glaube, das ist Geburtsrecht.
Geburtsrecht!
Es hat wohl auch viel damit zu tun,
ob die Eltern einem
das Gefühl geben,
dass man das haben müsste
oder nicht. - Ja.
Wie ist das bei ihnen?
Sie hatten für euch
ganz andere Pläne.
Man würde sogar verstehen,
wenn sie fänden,
ihr hättet sie im Stich gelassen.
- Ja, aber sie haben ...
Sylvias Eltern und meine Eltern ...
Wir wurden beide so erzogen,
dass wir für unser Glück
selbst verantwortlich sind.
Entsprechend
schauten wir für unser Glück.
Das ist jetzt halt im Ausland.
Es wäre auch nicht gut, wenn wir
noch bei ihnen in der Schweiz wären,
aber todtraurig.
Sie wären immer damit konfrontiert.
Jeden Sonntag träfen wir uns
zum Kaffee und wir wären immer ...
Hattet ihr nie Heimweh?
- Nein.
Ich hatte das aber noch nie.
Wir sind beide
schon immer sehr viel gereist.
Ich merkte schon in jungen Jahren,
dass ich nicht so
der Heimweh-Typ bin.
Denn das haben wir bei "Auf und
davon" doch ein paar Mal gesehen.
Leute hatten einen Plan A
und mussten plötzlich doch sagen:
"Irgendwie stimmt es nicht mehr.
Wir kehren zurück."
Bei "Auf und davon"
gab es also nicht nur Auswanderer,
sondern auch ein paar Rückkehrer.
Auf der philippinischen Insel Palawan
ist Auswanderer Jürg Senn
auf Einkaufstour -
alleine.
Seine Frau Birgit ist in der Schweiz.
Sie wurde von so starkem Heimweh
gequält, dass sie zurückkehrte,
vorläufig für einige Monate.
Jürg Senn hingegen
fühlt sich auf der Insel wohl.
Palawan ist wunderschön.
Was soll ich jammern?
Ich habe das Meer, ich kann tauchen,
das ganze Jahr über
ist es quietschgrün.
Ich habe freundliche Nachbarn,
überhaupt freundliche Leute.
Jürgs Frau
ist über 10'000 km weit entfernt.
Im zürcherischen Glattbrugg
hat Birgit Senn Unterschlupf
bei ihrer Tochter Lia gefunden.
Vorübergehend arbeitet sie
in einem Kindergarten.
Also ich bin nicht ...
Ich bin nicht auslandkompatibel.
Aber das ganze Projekt
ist absolut kein Misserfolg.
Es ist super,
es läuft perfekt, bestens.
Das einzige,
das nicht dorthin passt, bin ich.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Man hat so einen Wunsch,
sagt: "Wir machen ein Resort",
und plötzlich sagt der eine:
"Ich halte es hier nicht aus."
Dann denkt man: "Verdammt!"
"Wir sind ja erst
etwas mehr als ein Jahr hier."
Das ist schon etwas unverständlich,
v.a. weil man das als Mann
vielleicht etwas weniger spürt.
Also ich sowieso.
Wenn es nach mir geht, muss ich
nicht zurück in die Schweiz.
Das Gästehaus von Tschudis
war in den letzten Wochen ausgebucht.
Doch Tschudis geben auf.
Ich denke, das Heimweh hat mir einen
Strich durch die Rechnung gemacht.
Bali ist schön, aber ...
... es ist mir einfach zu weit.
Schon am Anfang sagte ich immer ...
Natascha war schon immer das Ding.
Ich denke,
lieber abbrechen als weiterführen.
Für Patrizia war die Sehnsucht
nach Tochter Natascha zu gross.
Jetzt reist auch
Backpackerin Sarah ab.
Letzter Gast.
Ja ...
Das war's.
- Ja.
Geht's, Schätzchen? Ach, komm!
* Einzelne
melancholische Klaviertöne *
Ja, ja.
* Schluchzen *
Schon gut.
* Kuss *
Was ist denn jetzt?
* Schluchzen *
Bald gehen wir nach Hause.
Wir hatten unter dem Strich
trotzdem eine gute Zeit. - Ja.
Gell!
- Ja.
Jetzt kommt wieder
ein neuer Abschnitt.
Der wird auch gut.
Dafür hast du das Mäuschen näher.
- Ja.
* Lachen *
Weisst du,
auch von den Leuten her ...
Es war schon schön,
mit den Leuten und so.
(Zwei, die schon mehr als einmal
allen Grund gehabt hätten,
in die Schweiz zurückzukommen, sind
Claudio Candrian und Teres Brunett.)
(Kaum waren sie
nach Venezuela ausgewandert,
haben sie
haarsträubende Sachen erlebt.)
Schon wieder?
Todesmutig rennt Teres nach draussen,
um die Diebe zu stellen.
Ich bin die Leiter hochgestiegen,
weil die schon hier war.
Ich habe gerufen:
"Ihr elendes Saupack!",
und wollte die Treppe runtergehen.
In dem Moment fiel ein Schuss
und ich habe einen starken Schlag
an den Kopf erhalten.
Sie haben mich angeschossen,
aber ich habe gleich gemerkt,
dass ich noch überlegen konnte,
also war es nicht so schlimm.
Aber es hat ziemlich geblutet
und ich wusste nicht,
ob ich einen Schock hatte
und die Schmerzen nicht spürte
oder was auch immer.
Das machte schon Eindruck,
so ein Schuss.
Zum Glück war es nur
ein Streifschuss.
Die ganze Ladung ging oben ans Haus
und zum Glück nicht in mein Gesicht.
Teres sagt,
sie habe an diesem Geburtstag
ein zweites Leben geschenkt bekommen.
Und
mit der allgegenwärtigen Kriminalität
müsse man halt leben lernen.
(Zehn Jahre später
schreckt Teres und Claudio
immer noch nichts ab.)
(Obwohl uns regelmässig Nachrichten
über die verheerenden Zustände
in Venezuela erreichen.)
(Das Land befindet sich
in einer miserablen Lage:
In den Läden
gibt es kaum mehr Lebensmittel
und andere elementare Güter
zu kaufen.)
(Trotzdem sind
die beiden Bündner immer noch da.)
Hallo in die Schweiz!
Uns geht es ein wenig wie dem Land.
Sagen wir mal:
alles etwas schwierig.
Die Situation
ist etwas schwierig hier.
Man sieht sie im Kehricht wühlen
usw.
Ja, es ist schlimm.
Und diese Überfälle ...
Mit der Zeit gewöhnt man sich daran
und achtet sich gar nicht mehr.
Ich war jetzt fünf Monate allein.
Kaum war Claudio weg, hatte ich
in dieser Zeit zwei Überfälle.
Oder versuchte Überfälle,
sagen wir es so.
Das zweite Mal,
als sie einbrechen wollten,
habe ich ihnen natürlich
Plomo gegeben.
Plomo heisst Blei.
- Blei, ja.
Ich habe doch noch nie geschossen
in meinem Leben.
Ich wollte schiessen,
aber der Schuss ging nicht raus.
Ich hatte die Sicherung nicht
weggenommen und musste fest drücken.
Ich bin wahnsinnig erschrocken
und hatte so Herzklopfen
und habe herumgeschrien.
Ich schrie: "Malandro!"
Aber kein einziger der Nachbarn kam.
Dann habe ich voll geschossen -
zum Glück habe ich nicht getroffen.
Sonst hätte ich
noch mal Probleme gehabt.
Im Nachhinein dachte ich:
Es war ja gut, dass ich nicht ...
Ja,
es war schon eine turbulente Zeit.
Dieses Jahr ist überhaupt
eine etwas turbulente Zeit.
("Eine turbulente Zeit"
ist ziemlich untertrieben.)
(In Venezuela ist
der Ausnahmezustand längst Alltag.)
(Demonstrationen, Zusammenstösse
zwischen Bürgern und Polizei -
nichts mehr erinnert ans Paradies,
das Teres und Claudio
seinerzeit gesucht haben.)
(Es wundert einen, dass die zwei
immer noch hier ausharren.)
(Wobei Claudio zwischenzeitlich
schon mal ein paar Monate
in der Schweiz verbracht
und ernsthaft
über seine Zukunft nachgedacht hat.)
Er bleibt noch in der Schweiz.
- Wer weiss.
Er sagt, er wisse nicht ...
- Es ist alles noch offen.
... er wisse nicht,
ob er zurückkomme.
Aber ich weiss sicher, dass ich
nicht in die Schweiz gehen kann.
Teres kann nicht gehen.
- Wegen der vielen Tiere.
Klar, ich habe meine Tochter
und meine Enkelkinder.
Es plagt mich schon,
dass ich nicht vermehrt
in die Schweiz reisen kann.
Es liegt auch finanziell nicht drin,
alle sechs Monate
in die Schweiz zu gehen.
Ich habe mittlerweile halt 28 Hunde,
17 Katzen, fünf Hühner, einen Hahn
und eine Henne mit vier Küken.
Also noch mit zwei.
- Nein, mit drei Küken.
Oder drei?
- Drei Küken.
Hier mache ich keinen Finger krumm.
Das hat sie sich eingebrockt,
also soll sie es selbst ausbaden.
Ich habe in der Garage Arbeit,
wunderbar, verdiene gutes Geld.
Gell?
- Ja.
Im Gegensatz zu Teres.
Sie gibt aus, bei mir kommt es rein.
Wir sagten:
Das ist Land Nummer 1 in Südamerika.
Als wir gekommen sind,
hatten sie wirklich alles.
Dass es so sehr abwärts geht,
hätten wir nicht träumen können.
Aber auch jetzt
verlassen wir diese Titanic nicht.
Sie ist noch nicht ganz am Sinken.
- Ich bin glücklich mit den Tieren.
V.a. wenn ich überall helfen kann.
V.a. auch die Tiere,
denn die können ja nicht so reden.
Und das Elend
ist hier schon auch sehr gross.
Für die Tiere
schaut hier niemand gross.
Wenn es nicht mal
für die Menschen reicht.
Ja, eben. Darum ist Teres hier.
Ich denke immer,
es war vielleicht eine Bestimmung,
dass ich hier gelandet bin.
- Ich glaube auch.
Ich hätte das auch nicht gedacht,
dass ich mal so viele ...
* Tonausfall *
Tschüss. Tschau, tschau.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
(Der Kontrast
könnte nicht grösser sein.)
(Über Schweden liegt ein Frieden,
der einem in der Seele guttut.)
(Familie Buob macht sich bereit
für einen Ausflug
an einen besonders schönen Ort.)
* Lachen *
Bist du bereit für den Ausflug?
Darf ich auch noch rauskommen?
Danke, Juna.
* Juna spricht unverständlich. *
Ja.
Willst du sie schon anziehen?
- Nein.
Schau, Mona muss sich auch
ganz warm anziehen. - Ja, du.
Für ins Auto kannst du
diese Jacke anziehen, Juna.
* Erhabene Klavier-
und Streichklänge *
(Wenn man nämlich von Snokebo
eine gute Autostunde
Richtung Osten fährt,
kommt man zu den berühmten Schären.)
(Das sind viele kleine Inseln
und Felsen an der Küste,
die in der Eiszeit
rundgeschliffen wurden.)
(Die Weite dieses fantastischen Orts
lädt förmlich ein,
ein wenig über das Erreichte
nachzudenken.)
Hier rauf.
Rückblickend, nach zwei Jahren -
seid ihr auch überrascht,
wie gut es geklappt hat?
Ja.
- Oder eher, wie hart es war?
Nein, wir haben schon
damit gerechnet, dass es hart wird.
Denn es wartet ja niemand auf dich.
Es steht niemand hier und sagt:
"Juhui, zwei Schweizer kommen."
Wir sind davon ausgegangen,
dass es hart wird.
Du hoffst, dass es einfacher geht,
aber du weisst genau:
Es wird harzig sein,
es braucht Zeit.
Wir haben uns einfach
fünf Jahre gegeben. - Genau.
Was habt ihr
beim Auswandern gefunden?
Das Glück.
- Mhm.
(Und genau das -
nämlich das Glück -
suchen auch
unsere nächsten Abenteurer.)
(Übermorgen Abend geht es schon los
mit neuen Geschichten
bei "Auf und davon".)
* Schiffshorn *
An der rauen Nordsee
wittern Sacha und Brigitte Kunz
ihre grosse Chance.
Mehr zum Spass sagten wir:
So etwas sollte man haben.
Am Wattenmeer übernehmen sie einen
Imbiss mit Currywurst und Pommes.
Nicht mehr Ferien, sondern arbeiten.
Genau, aber schönes Arbeiten,
wenn man da die Landschaft anschaut.
Ich glaube, einen schöneren
Arbeitsplatz gibt es nicht.
Für ihren Traum gibt die fünfköpfige
Familie ihr Heim im Baselbiet auf.
Von Frühjahr bis Herbst
stehen sie hinter der Fritteuse.
Schatz, da!
- Currywurst, Pommes, Mayo.
Das Geschäft
steht und fällt mit dem Wetter.
Jetzt bauen wir den Wagen um,
damit wir fliehen können,
wenn das Wasser kommt.
Kann Familie Kunz tatsächlich
von Würsten, Frikadellen
und Pommes frites leben?
Familie Almeida aus dem Kanton Zürich
zieht es in den Osten Kanadas.
Unter Tränen
brechen sie ins neue Leben auf.
Viel Glück.
- Danke. Dir auch. Macht's gut.
In der Provinz Nova Scotia
übernehmen die Almeidas
ein Motel aus den 60er-Jahren.
There was a crack up there.
Es ist so ein wenig eine Wundertüte.
Das ist kein Hilton, Schätzchen.
Ruedi und Susanne Althaus stürzen
sich in Südamerika ins Abenteuer.
Unser neues Daheim.
Einfach noch ohne Haus.
Sie gehen auf und davon
Richtung Uruguay.
Wir geben viel auf:
das Geregelte, die Sicherheit,
die haben wir nicht mehr.
Das 7-Zimmerhaus im Emmental,
in dem sie
ihre drei Buben aufgezogen hatten,
tauschen Ruedi und Susanne vorerst
gegen einen Container in der Pampa.
Sie rücken zusammen
und leben zu zweit auf 14 m2.
Cool! Aber kalt.
* Lachen *
Es ist fast wie im Skilager.
- Salud.
Die neue Staffel von "Auf und davon":
übermorgen auf SRF 1.
Es ist wahnsinnig schön.
# U sie stigen i Flüger,
flüge mit de Vögu furt,
# chöme nümme hei.
# U si lö hie aues zrugg,
uf der Suechi für nes neus Dehei.
# Sie göh hüt no uf u drvo.
# Uf u dervo!
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2019
(Hermann Schönbächler)
Also, komm, halt dich fest.
Mit der anderen Hand auch.
So, komm. Richi!
Ich habe gesagt, du sollst dich
gut festhalten! * Weinen *